[Music]
season 10 here we go
is this a good season a hard season a
tough season how would you describe it
for yourself it's all of them but most
of all it's a strong season is there
anything you're dreading having to
relive and watch back yes I'm dreading
till we live Bethany
calling me you're calling me that
horrible name it was very hurtful and it
was mean and it was unnecessary Real
Housewives of New York City star Dorinda
medley getting real with et about this
upcoming moment from season 10
you're a drop you know I have a life now
that's not the life that I expected in
that moment when she called you a drunk
did you have a visceral reaction right
then I said I said I said I don't think
that's true because I thought like you
know it would be like me seeing her
break down about her dog and saying that
she's mentally ill well okay he just
don't do that
that's what Bethenny likes to do every
but every year she she has to label
someone this you're a [ __ ] you're a
loser you're I mean this year you got no
you're a drunk I actually thought it was
ridiculous and I think people are kind
of getting sick of that too but I think
it did what she wanted it to do was
which was make an impact yeah and get
her on TV do you think the home front
yes as a constructive ability to make
that happen when you see those moments
back of yourself yeah in that kind of
state drunk yes what what do you think I
think oh my god those orange drinks got
to be but there's not an issue there's
not a drinking table now one of the
things that I realized that actually was
one of the reasons I was sort of like
you know a little drinking away
maestro's is I was really sad last fall
I was I was going through something I
realized Hannah moved out that job was
over what do I do now there was a
transitional feeling a little bit like
Miss place instead of making any big
sweeping movements I just stopped you
guys stopped running in the wind I let
the wind just sort of pass me by and I
started to realize hmm this is kind of
nice you know I can be selfish I don't
have to look after anyone except me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]